this says azerbaijan will soon be a
village in nagorno-karabakh with its own
schools civil services and agriculture
the pilot project is promoted as a new
beginning in a land that for decades has
been ravaged by conflict a six-week war
with armenia ended in november last year
and azerbaijan took control of several
areas of nagorno-karabakh as part of a
ceasefire deal
now the focus is on developing the
territory building peace bringing the
normal life back to this region means
unlocking all these communications will
help or benefit not only azerbaijan but
also georgia russia iran turkey and even
armenia i would say
the village of jojo marijuana was built
for returning displaced azeri's in 2017
after fighting the year before
here the hazard family knows what it's
like to start over
they were pushed out of their hometown
when armenian communities moved in
during the 1990s
they are rebuilding our villages and
launching large-scale construction
projects this makes us very happy we
will thrive
but dangerous linger the peace deal has
been tested by fighting at the border in
their land mines and unexploded bombs in
the area
still developments like this new airport
are forging ahead there are no planes
and no passengers yet but local leaders
say that will change this airport took
eight months to build and opened a month
ago the azerbaijani government thinks it
will be a vital part of karabaw's
economy in the years and decades to come
the airport is the gateway to karabaw
will bring jobs for the local community
azerbaijan
airport may be new but the area around
it carries a long and bloody history
much like the road that leads to it
nagorno-karabakh may have a long way to
go before it fully opens to the nearly
one million azeri's who want to call it
home cinema solo fazuli azerbaijan